chaos walking a movie once deemed
supposedly unreleasable by some studio
executives at lionsgate but now
it's worthy of being released apparently
this is a long time coming i believe
production started in 2017 i want to say
reshoots took place in 2019 but of
course tom holland and daisy ridley
became super duper famous off of some
franchises they worked on and now here
we are today
spider-man meets ray hey man if you've
got it lying around you might as well
release it
and if you're gonna do chaos walking in
the year 2020 it sure is a good year to
capitalize on some chaos let's do this
[Music]
he looks so much younger to be skinnier
stop don't go any closer
[Music]
i'm sorry i've just never seen a girl
before
who are you
it's so loud here
oh
i love me some mass mickelson man why is
she thinking where the hell is your
noise
it's strange to see everything you're
thinking it was strange for me too not
knowing what's going on in your head
i mean i know you might not like my dog
you want
damn
[Music]
you want to protect the girl you have to
leave now
that's damian beshear
[Music]
[Music]
oh
daisy ridley's top built
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's a scary position to be in yeah
definitely because the more you try not
to think the more you're going to think
they need to do some meditation courses
you get some head space on this planet
that they're on man
that's right that'll be the key at the
very end that'll solve everything
it looks like there's a lot a lot of
moving pieces here happening
everyone hears their own thoughts they
call it the noise daisy ridley
first woman in a long time to be on a
planet full of men it's like alien
three it's like a quiet place
you know there you go it's a whole bunch
of movies all combined into one i
honestly expected something to look
pretty terrible even if i wasn't told
that information even if i didn't have
lowered expectations going into seeing
this trailer
i just had a complete blank slate no
predetermined thoughts
i'd still walk out of this going it
looks pretty cool that looks awesome
yeah yeah and i wonder if maybe what
they're talking about
is just it looks like it's doing yeah a
whole lot of different things and it
reminded me of several different sci-fi
movies but strung together by enough
intriguing sort of unique imagery that i
was like you got stuff that looks really
futuristic you've got stuff that looks
really rustic and western almost
i wonder yeah just how all those
elements will coalesce together the only
thing that really
struck me with any kind of eyebrow rays
at all was like some of the humorous
moments seemed like they were maybe a
little forced but again those are things
that could easily breathe a lot better
in a scene with the benefits of
chemistry so like doug lyman seems like
a director who's apt to push
boundaries at least in terms of sci-fi
you know and bring us something that is
ambitious but well realized
i'm curious as to what this is going to
become because plenty of movies have the
stigma of oh man it was unreleasable we
did a bunch of reshoots it's a
frankenstein it's been sitting around
for so long and then come out and are
actually quite smooth and enjoyable so
like yeah as a trailer and if i didn't
know all that i would just be
excited to check this out because yeah
it looks again like it could
fall into being just derivative of a lot
of other sci-fi movies or
if it nails its promise it looks like it
could be pretty interesting and the only
then gripe i have is you know if it's
not rated r you know it's not going to
be too realistic in terms of what
thoughts are displayed
the thoughts that enter a planet full of
men's minds i can only imagine
yeah i mean you can get pretty uh
repulsive with the thought process there
if you wanted to go full
hard r with the thought process
something that felt like degrading i
don't know if there'd be like some type
of
room for commentary here i know the book
series is really beloved because at the
time when this got picked up
it was around the time of the y a surge
you know there's like twilight hunger
games where lionsgate was really
capitalizing on all those things
divergent and fifth weight yeah and then
there was like
2011 i believe when it was picked up
didn't start getting a film until 2017
and the author of the book he helped
with the rewrites for what they did for
the reshoots here
what we're getting in terms of like a
sci-fi picture i think it looks
surprisingly really intense those scenes
with mads mickelson specifically with
mads mikkelsen and daisy ridley going
back and forth
it looks like the way how doug lyman is
doing composition with his shots is
different from the other movies he's
done before and i also think doug lyman
movies i like doug lyman a lot as a
director i think he's a wonderful
director
a lot of his movies often get some of
the worst trailers
and i think that's why i thought this
would be a bad trailer too edge of
tomorrow wasn't a great trailer even the
bourne identity
wasn't a great trailer you know and
sometimes he doesn't do great movies
like didn't they end up not being good
but most of the time i think he does a
really good job and this to me it's it's
like it has some of the ear marks of a
why a novel for sure a romance element
that is possibly happening but i love
how that wasn't even capitalized on it's
like tom holland's really good at
playing
uncomfortable you know like exactly
playing the dude who feels kind of
nervous he's really good at that
and it feels just the right tone because
i agree with you on the sense that some
of the humor
feels a little bit forced and kind of
out of place for such a dark serious
heavy trailer
yet the way the scene interaction was
going it didn't seem like he was
upping it too much in terms of being
cause this is easily a situation like
you could oh
a woman yeah you could do it you should
go way over the top
you know yeah exactly like oh my god i
want to do something none of us have
seen a woman in so long but then there's
also the mystery angle with daisy ridley
in fact i think that surprised me one of
the only thing that really surprised me
in this trailer than the fact that i
thought it looked good
yes chaos going on outside as well too
the thing that surprised me out of the
fact it looked good
that daisy ridley is top build in here
instead of tom holland
i'm not saying i mean yeah i think tom
holland has a little bit more
star cloud than daisy really he is a
more
wide net but this trailer read to me
that
daisy ridley is more of the supporting
mysterious character because she falls
from the sky we don't really know what
her whole ordeal is
tom holland read to me as more of the
main lead character
so i'm wondering what we're going to
uncover about her i'm sure it's all in
the books
that i could find out um but mads
mickelson looks great
you know you always got damian uh demian
damien
damion bashir and what is it they can
you
if you've read the book please feel free
to elaborate more clarified are they
they're able to conjure up certain
imagery from the earth
because they can hear each other's
thoughts but they cannot the thing with
the snake they can also conjure up
there was a stray line in there that
said something about like oh with
abilities like his
or whatever so i wonder if maybe tom
holland has like yeah some special
ability to conjure up
like if he imagines a snake like that
intently
maybe he can conjure up something that
at least if not physically real to
somebody is
visible yeah like maybe and this also
seemed to really capitalize on the mood
and the tone
and much less the romance trying to make
up for the noise outside
it seems to really capitalize on the
mood and the tone more than it is
trying to oh tom hall and daisy ridley
what are they gonna get together it was
more about the suspense
and i think the visual effects look
really solid too yeah
yeah i mean the sci-fi trimmings of it
look really exciting to me and look like
the stuff that doug lyman's name excites
me for
because part of what was so great about
edge of tomorrow is like wow this is
like a really
gripping piece of sci-fi action as well
as you know like
a well-made movie and so uh yeah like
the sci-fi elements here i like anything
that takes
clearly futuristic aspects with like
space travel and whatnot but then
strands you in a very grounded
environment and how those things mix
i do wonder if the whole thing with the
the flames around the head
looks like flames but the thought
process of the noise if that'll come
across a little cheesy
when actually watching the film i'll get
his jokes daisy ridley falling from the
sky
space yeah from space tom holland kind
of feels a little bit
like his character and the devil all the
time but with spidey sense
yeah it also speaks his mind but we'll
see guys i mean
i was pleasantly surprised by this we'll
see how it turns out all right guys what
you think of the chaos walking trailer
leave your thoughts down below once you
go ahead and subscribe to the real
rejects and click that notification bell
leave your thoughts down because i'm
curious to see
if people are having a positive response
to this last but not least we'll do a
pic
mikepdf15 now mypdf15 he pledged to our
patreon page
all the way back the beginning of
october still
haven't heard back from this guy to give
him a more personalized customized
shout out i wonder what he is thinking
right now is he thinking maybe greg and
john would have given him a better shout
out on a video but there wasn't so much
chaos of people walking around outside
is there chaos happening in your life
that's not allowing you
to just type a little bit of a it's
going well cause i think i'll be asked
is
how are you doing i mean that's a
chaotic question there are a lot of ways
to answer it but please don't be
shy okay that's one way to miss out on
all the wonderful chaos that life has to
offer you
unlike the chaos outside of our window
at the moment
well mike happy thanksgiving and i'm
grateful to have you a part of our
patreon page anyway
much love